I went from 10K to a million in 1
month no so I started making videos for
a niche audience at first like K-Pop
videos once I started to move my content
to relate to people of all backgrounds
and identities that's when my real
audience came to me I think the best
creativity comes when you're working
within a box so if you think of the
algorithm as these parameters that you
have to hit you can tell the best story
within those parameters honorable
energetic radiant and optimistic scaling
the business up we have an amazing
content and formats that work so well
we're really trying to take it to the
next level without losing the quality of
what we do what's next is I'm working on
this new series Allen's Universe which
is released on my channel so proud of it